can you guard it with this yeah we can
see they can see this this is how it
went down yeah like this is in it 100%
one two three four five I feel like I've
got two now and please to actually do
this more often so here we go ideas or
executions the game hustle would be
putting effort into achieving the ball
at hand we mean that means making every
minute felt punched me in the face
8,000 times I'm here to get punched
Michael asks how do you define Hospital
yo I need a problem that's your brain or
let me tell you something more which is
I like the process of the world I sell
some it's what I do
very special
LTV the thing that I live like I'm value
one two three four five I'm ready India
let's get into the show
Kobe the Kobe okay
homie what are you at look no I see
right that was a bad yeah there was no
reason to go to India there miss play by
you the rock miss play he ruck miss play
it was a good show I liked the show my
motivation comes from a couple places
one I love what I do I love the drive I
love the client I love working I love
I asked the question of the day that was
already done in there uh it was a good
show I like that show
fast and furious then I'll just get sued
you keep asking questions I'll keep
answering them